[Music]
good afternoon everyone I hope I'm not
going to put anyone to sleep it's right
after lunch so we'll try to get it make
it very very exciting exciting in the
Google bigquery style I am
Abhishek I'm a product manager on the
Google bigquery team and we'll be
talking about bigquery ml which we
announced at the keynote this morning
and in this session I'll be joined by
Naveed Hamid who has been one of our
alpha customers and Naveed will share
his experiences on the use case they
picked for Hearst Newspapers and how
they implemented it before we start
talking I just wanted to point out that
you can actually ask a question through
the Q&A link in your next app and we'll
get to those questions during the Q&A
part at the end of the presentation so
let's start with how many of you use
bigquery that's amazing thank you and I
see a lot of hands did not go up so I'll
spend just a minute introducing what it
is so bigquery is Google clouds
enterprise class data warehouse we have
customers who have petabytes of data and
you can actually write a single query to
analyze all of that at once you can use
standard sequel it's Google so data is
encrypted data is durable highly
available the key part of bigquery is
that it's server less and fully managed
which means all you care about is what
data you have how you want to analyze it
and let us take care of how many nodes
you need in the back so the concept of
node does not exist which means your
life is much much easier and finally you
can actually do you can actually use it
for real-time analytics as well so what
does it mean a lot of you who have used
bigquery
can attest to the fact that having it
being serverless has really changed how
data warehousing is done as your life
has become much much easier by focusing
just on the analysis and not worry about
how it will scale when you go to
petabytes of data with bigquery ml we
are bringing the same to machine
learning people say AI is changing the
world but in reality even though even
though you can think of use cases which
can become predictive it's very very
hard to actually use machine learning so
that's what we are doing with bigquery
ml and to illustrate it let's look at
how machine learning may look like in a
couple of forms let's say you have a few
terabytes of data in your data warehouse
it could be bigquery or a different one
how do you do machine learning the first
step in almost every instance we have
seen is to export the data out so you go
discover the data you want to use for
training your model you export it if
you're lucky to have a data science team
they will fall Mattituck to the your
favorite Python framework and come back
to you in a few weeks saying oh we need
more data and you just take months to
build that model if you don't have a
data science team you just take a very
very small sample you move it to excel
and you just run basic regression and I
have talked to customers who say even
the Excel based approach takes months to
build a model and updated so the two
underlying problems for ml are one doing
even the smallest ml project needs data
scientists and there are just too few of
them you can it requires so much
understanding of math or so much
understanding of hyper parameter tuning
that that becomes a bottleneck the
second is
it takes multiple tools and it takes
moving data out to even start a machine
learning project and all these are just
productivity hassles that prevent you
from trying out the cool ml stuff you
have for your analysis so that's what
bigquery ml enables we are introducing a
way to do machine learning using sequel
staying within bigquery
right where you write your select
statement you just start doing machine
learning on the data you already have so
what do you get from this you can build
your own machine learning models in
standard sequel you can predict in
standard sequel as well
the models stay within bigquery you can
train it on whatever data you want to
train it on within the query but data
that with bigquery federates from other
sources and finally you only have to
worry about the data and sequel we take
care of the underlying hyper parameter
tuning and we take care of feature
transformation standardization and other
things that usually are part of a
machine learning workflow to give you a
more practical example let's say you
have marketing data coming into bigquery
so you get data from your website
visitors from Google Analytics you have
first-party data from your customer
relationship management platform you
move it to bigquery because that's where
it's so easy to join and analyze it now
the rather than just looking at
historical trends if you wanted to start
making predictions for your marketing
counterparts you would write a model
using bigquery ml you will take those
predictions report it out who your
favorite be a platform and you would
production realize it by connecting it
with your marketing automation systems
to take action based on these
actions and in all of this since you do
it in bigquery it is all sequel it's
very very easy to set this workflow up
and when you want to retrain this model
with new data you just use air flow or
cloud composer so you can actually get
to a fully production model and we'll
have Navi talk about it later in this
session staying within bigquery
I'll give a few more examples to get you
thinking about what kind of fuse cases
it can empower you for so these are some
of our public alpha customers we had
quite a successful alpha and these are
the use cases that some of these pursued
so Hearst will learn more about it later
they used it for cus customer churn
prediction 20th Century Fox presented in
the keynote today where they talked
about how they are now optimizing their
media plans for new movies using
bigquery ml geotab just gave a demo at
the spotlight session just before this
one where they have an app for smart
cities and one of those plugins is to
predict if there's going to be bad
driving in a particular neighborhood
based on the weather so they again use
the public data set on whether that's
with in bigquery combined it with their
telematics data and they can now say
okay based on the weather forecast for
the next seven days these are the places
where you may see aggressive driving or
too much braking all accidents and city
planners can then plan things much much
better and again they did that of
staying within bigquery
just using sequel or we have news UK who
are using this for customer subscription
prediction again using data that they
get from a variety of sources in
bigquery smart parking they are an IOT
company out of Australia New Zealand
they are using it for graphic prediction
and we blaze who's one of our partners
cloud armor is actually using them in
the back
and they are using it to automate IP
address threat prediction
something they used to do using
heuristics before
so all these use cases have been enabled
across these customers who just did not
have enough data scientists to do
machine learning for each of these
business decisions I will show you a
quick demo of how this works and to set
it up let's say you have a marketer at a
retail e-commerce company and one of the
very common problems is that if you have
a million visitors a month to your
website how do you plan your marketing
campaigns to them if you know and we
actually have data from the Google
merchandise store that shows on the 0.7%
of website visitors actually come back
and make a purchase with that low the
return on investment from your marketing
you're not going to target all of them
so in this example I'll show you how
using machine learning you can do a much
much better job at planning your
marketing campaigns and if you can
please switch to the demo screen so this
is the new bigquery UI that we launched
recently and I'm sure a lot of you are
familiar with their data so what it
shows is we have this public data set
from Google Analytics from the Google
merchandise store we are selecting a few
free columns from this to use as
features and if you think about
marketing data some of these features
are very very obvious that you believe
are going to have predictive influence
on if a person will come back and
purchase or not and you just select
these like how many page views happened
in a session did the person buy where
the person come from was it from a
desktop was it from a cellphone or what
country was it so you select these you
do not select the person's ID because
that's not useful and all you do is you
say I want to create a model and you
give it a name the only options you need
to give is what type of a model it is we
support linear and logistic regression
for forecasting or classification based
on your use case so in this case you are
going to predict a label that says will
this visitor come back and buy and just
telling us what the label is on top of
your regular sequel query in this
example we took the first nine months of
data to train this model you just simply
let it go and this will take a few
minutes to finish its working on a very
large of set of complex data but what
you get at the end of it once you have
this model you use it for predictions
you can build a report which is what any
marketer does in this case it's on data
studio that shows that if you were to
just target the top 60 60 percent up 6
percent of the scored leads you actually
get 9 times the people who come back and
purchase and this was on the last three
months of test data and furthermore you
capture 50 percent of the potential
buyers
so both the precision and the recall of
this model is really high and if you
look back at the create model statement
we had you actually did not have to give
any hyper parameter tuning
options you did not have to do anything
except just select the right features
and if you selected more that don't
matter those will be involved ignored
with the low weight anyways so in this
example with a couple of lines of sequel
code you actually can manage to get nine
times the ROI on your marketing
campaigns still reaching 50% of the
population and if you
were to think about the typical machine
learning matrix this model looks really
good the ROC curve here is actually the
best you can get it's very hard to get a
heart better IOC curve and similarly the
precision and recall curves are really
good so to bigquery ml you got a model
you could predict and those of you who
actually want to dive into the
performance metrics it's really easy to
do that as well let's see if it's still
running so if we can go back to the
presentation please thank you so what
happened behind the scenes you go to
create model you did not have to think
about the infrastructure at all it
created a bunch of queries on bigquery
highly parallelized it and gave you the
answer so determining the infrastructure
thinking about how many compute hours I
need do I have two VMs to have six VMs
all that is distraction with bigquery
you built a model without having to
think anything about it second there's a
hyper parameter called learning rate
which is how fast you want to change
your parameters we auto-tune that one
you never want to create your model on
all of training data so to prevent
overfitting
we Auto split data into training and set
you did not have to do that in that
example either when you think about
numeric numeric features we
automatically standardized those again
it's a very basic task has to be done
why leave it to the user we just do it
and finally for string features we
one-hot encode them so anything that
needs to be a category we see it and we
run hot encoding and this is just a
start as you think about automation of
all these basic transformations and
feature engineering will just keep on
adding to it and this should suffice a
lot of the use cases for the advanced
user who may want to do more we actually
do give the knobs so if you want to use
say Alvin regularization so you get
weights close to zero or one for
different features you have that option
you say a random training test data
split does not work I want to do
sequential well I want to flag and split
them myself you can do that as well you
want to set your own learning rate you
can do that as well so the philosophy is
you get a great model out of the box and
if you want to further find to you in it
we have the options for you thinking
about what we support so you can use
standard sequel you can use UDF's within
the queries if you have a forecasting
use case let's say you want to forecast
the sales of a skew you want to forecast
the number of users on your website you
can do it use using linear regression if
you want to classify say Willa user come
back and make a purchase in this example
so if you wanted to say with a user
subscribe with a user churn all those
things you can do using logistic
regression for evaluation of models we
have table valued functions that you can
use to get all standard metrics that you
may be used to if you already know some
machine learning and for the district
regression you can get the agassi curve
and precision we call numbers as well if
you want to look at the model weights to
explain to someone which features
mattered more and which mattered less we
have an ml dot weight Steve EF for that
one and finally to do your feature
engineering you can actually get there's
a function called ml dot feature info
and you can use that function to use C
standard starts like min max standard
dev
on each of these features that went into
your model as we announced it we
realized that bigquery UI is not the
only place that our users users from so
we have integrations with data studio
local and tableau and if you go through
our documentation if you go through your
documentation you can find out more but
in this example on the Left tableau has
built UI based housing price prediction
tools which is a really hot topic but in
this case using a model built in
bigquery ml you can get predictions out
of the box on the right you see the data
studio performance report I just showed
and at the bottom you see the
performance report on Luca and with Luca
we actually have the deepest integration
so one they have blocks so you can
explore the data in bigquery second
using look ml which is their markup
language you can actually create models
staying within Luca and finally you can
operationalize your ml workflow to look
at as well if you take a step back and
think where it fits because everyone
talks a lot a lot about ml google
announces things in tensorflow things
about auto ml where does bigquery ml
fact we see this as a centerpiece in
making ml accessible for all audiences
tensorflow Cloud ml engine is for the
data scientist to build the
state-of-the-art neural network base
model that's required for a very high
performance application Auto ml
leverages the Google IP on standard
problem sets like object detection in
images
object detection in videos semantic
understanding on text and gives you the
gifts our developer the ability to use
that as an API to build those models but
what about all these business use cases
which for which speed is more important
and for which it's more important to
have someone who understands the data to
build a model using the tools you know
that's what bigquery ml is for it's for
our big query data analysts who work
with data are day-in day-out
love sequel but it's probably too much
to ask to have them go learn tensorflow
to go set of five different tools moved
it out of bigquery just to be able to
build a model so that's where it fits
within our portfolio we have auto ml for
developers my query ml for analysts and
tensorflow
c ml e for data scientists and if you
think about the use cases in different
industries any business use case you see
from prediction of lifetime value - if
you are in a gaming company what action
will this play or take will this player
come back the next day if you think
about IOT downtime prediction so things
which require a lot of data that is or
can be in bigquery which is structured
you can use bigquery ml to start
approaching those use cases it's really
easy to get started with and once you
get going then you can improve your
models and put them into production with
that I'm going to call Navid from Hearst
to talk about their experience with
bigquery ml and how they have actually
implemented it in production
[Applause]
hello my name is Naveen Amma
I'm a senior director for data
engineering and machine learning at
Hearst Newspapers so you might not have
heard about Hearst Hearst is a very
large media company you might have heard
about names such as s San Francisco
Chronicle or SF Gate or magazines like
Esquire or cosmopolitan and there's many
many more companies under the Hearst
umbrella and you should like you can
look it up on the Hearst website or the
Hearst Newspapers I'm here talking about
Hearst Newspapers and its application
for bigquery ml Hearst employs about
4,000 employees across the nation and it
focuses on on local newspapers
it has about 40-plus websites and it's
continuously growing by acquiring more
websites and this is a picture of the
Hearst building in New York very close
to Central Park
so why bigquery ml for Hearst newspaper
so we're already a big shop a bigquery
we have a whole bunch of data sets
already sitting in bigquery such as
Google Analytics our subscription data
newsletter usage demographics so since
this data was already there in bigquery
just made sense to when I heard about
this feature a few months ago
let's give it a give bigquery ml a shot
so another thing is anybody who is
familiar with the SQL syntax can really
get on board doing data science you need
to learn a basic concepts like precision
recall or ROC which somebody can pick up
very quickly but you don't have to be
like familiar with Python or some like
like scikit-learn or tensorflow to be
able to use this another benefit is that
you don't have to eat
out data do machine learning do all that
massaging in a like a script like Python
and ingest it back and put into reports
that whole cycle just gets cut down
dramatically because you do everything
and bigquery and some of the other
goodies with BQ ml is it does
normalization one hot encoding as a be
shake already mentioned and then you can
also after training the model you can
get the training the machine learning
matrix using sequel syntax as well so
the use case that we developed is churn
prediction churn prediction is to
predict given your existing subscribe to
subside how likely are they to cancel
their subscription in the future and
this is a very relevant use cases for
media because you probably have heard in
news that people have lots of choices
print people tend to go from print to
digital so this is if we could save some
of our subscribers I looked up some
proverb for this or what money saved as
money made then I thought maybe there's
other proverbs that apply to this
scenario for example a prevention is
better than cure and I have another one
that'll use it as an easter egg for my
talk tomorrow so I'm having talked about
machine learning for a in context of
publication talks about features about B
qml Auto ml have applied natural
language processing and tensorflow
in in the space of media so if you find
that relevant please attend a ton and
this gives insights into future of a
cancellation of subscriptions and this
is a binary classification problem
people who canceled and who didn't so
that fits very nicely into the logistic
regression facilities offered by BQ ml
and we had like we took a year's worth
of data for our subscriptions newsletter
demographics web browsing behavior
customer and customer service data
sitting and bqm up so when I put this
diagram it's really the architecture is
really two nodes I just try to fill this
up diagram with all these different
steps really its bigquery and looker so
everything you do is in bigquery and and
our procedure really is we're each
yelling our standard ETL process into
bigquery and and then we do some
pre-processing we pre process some of
the more complicated sequels or like pre
create those tables especially with
google analytics like the linkage of
subscription data to Google Analytics we
want to compute that before and then
once we have all our tables it's really
a matter of running this create models
SQL which basically has one big table
with a whole bunch of features from all
these different data sets and a label
column which says is this person going
to cancel or not and we're using last
year of data splitting into to have six
months of data where we extracting
feature and from that six month point
onward we know which subscribers cancel
and who didn't and then you run the
sequel you know go for a cup of tea or
coffee and then come back and your model
is ready for a usage and then we take
the existing subscriber with the same
feature set and run it through the
predict and SQL and then it produces a
probability score for each subscriber
how likely is to cancel and then on top
of it we've built look our dashboards
which may display the there are n data
like how likely a person is to cancel or
not and also the machine learning
matrices we can see how good or bad this
machine learning model did like show the
weights that it learned just to get more
idea what's happening
so this is a snapshot of our dashboard
so it's probably hard to see but over
here this look shows you for each
subscription I have raised out their
subscription IDs like what is the top
people we're going to cancel their
subscription so so this is something
that a marketer or a person dealing with
subscription retention can look at and
take action on right besides that we can
see look at the score this is the area
under the curve which essentially is in
this graph it shows the area under this
curve and all of these major that you
can get from the sequel the ROC sequel
supported in Baku mo and this other
graph with the the next question is once
you've done this modeling what is your
cutoff threshold like is are you going
to take 50% and above and call them
churners or 30% and above no so using
the same RSC we're plotting the false
positive rate and the true positive rate
and then each threshold shows what that
is so we are objective is to have a hive
true positive and a low false positive
rate so about at point three we have
about 20% false positive and 80 percents
true positive which I feel is a good
trade-off between them because the worst
case scenario is that you're going to
some send some extra emails or messaging
it doesn't hurt if those people didn't
actually turn out to be churners and
then we're plotting out the weights so
on the left side these are the positive
weights and this is another sequel from
B QML and these are the negative ways so
the positive weight means that they have
a positive correlation to churning while
the negative one which is good for us
like good for retaining survivors are
negatively correlated and there's two
type of features one and you have to
tweak your sequel if
they're categorical features then you
have to like understand use a slightly
separate syntax to extract so we've
plotted both of them I've deliberately
erase the features because that gives
out some of the key findings that we
made from this so these are the benefits
that we see from bigquery ml so when
when I heard about it and I had previous
experience building churn modeling I
actually build out that sequel a very
one feature based a churn model in a day
since we had that data sitting there was
a matter of coming up with a sequel as
you seen in the demo it's not very
difficult and then we spent like a few
Sprint's refining that model and and it
really was like getting more features
testing it out looking at the matrix
does it make sense so it was like that
cycle was what we did in sprint and also
of course build that dashboard and
looker
if it was some other scikit-learn you
would have been pulling this data out
into another system and this to sprint
could have become like six brands or a
much longer time and we focus on the
problem rather than the data sciency
nuances and the feature engineering is
clearly laid out in sequel so if a new
person looks at it anybody familiar with
sequel can easily understand what's
going on rather than looking at Python
or our code along with sequel and it's
easy to onboard new members people real
familiar with sequel were not actually
developers but we're kin bi or other
departments can or who are willing to
learn sequel can actually use this and
then also it utilize the scale of a big
query so since it's a distributed dream
we'll based thing you can run your
models on larger data sets in a quicker
time
right thank you
[Applause]
yep
so let's before we wrap it up let's go
back and look at what happens to the
model can you switch to the demo screen
please so as you can see the model was
built the model is stored with its own
icon in bigquery these are the training
starts so when you're building the model
you want to look at what the data loss
was and this shows the features and
labels that went into building the model
so when you start using it you are going
to start seeing model as a new type that
showing up on your bigquery console and
then you can start using it for
predictions to get the dashboard reports
that we saw so can we go back to the
presentation thank you so just you
finish it what can you do going out of
this if you want to try machine learning
I think the first step is to identify
the use case and as no adventure and
look at what's the most important for
your company then see is it a
forecasting problem or classification
and then you can use the relevant
problem type you can go to the bigquery
console and start using it today if you
have any feedback please send it to us
it's a public beta now we will look at
it and get back to you and finally we
have included it in the Coursera course
on data analytics and using this QR code
it's or going to next 18 it's actually
free for the next month so you can go
and learn more it will walk you through
a few examples
and actually get you started so we have
some time for Q&A and just to remind
again you can ask them using your app or
you can ask them at the mic here and
once through the app which we do not
cover today we will get to them by
tomorrow so you can come back and check
for the answers thank you
[Music]